[Music]
welcome welcome back friends and family
welcome to the worth it holiday special
where Adam Andrew and I are going to be
hosting a very special potluck for our
friends that's right in three parts we
are going behind the scenes to see how
each dish is gonna be made gonna be some
homemade stuff some restaurant stuff
some expensive showstopper stuff and we
quite arrived today so part one what
you're watching right now
appetizers next week part twos desserts
desserts part three the grand finale
where the whole feast is gonna happen
we're gonna be preparing a delicious big
meat that's right Andrew and I in the
kitchen it's about time right
are you actually cleaning these glasses
or the other dusty oh can you help yeah
get a towel you my show today I worth it
we're gonna be trying to our potluck
appetizers one that is prepared at a
restaurant one that is homemade and
they're both gonna be worth it because
all it is Rock and this is worth it not
everyone has time to cook something
themselves no shame sometimes you got to
go and pick up something from a
restaurant so our friends Brandon and my
eita are gonna be showing us this little
Brazilian treat it's Brazilian cheese
bread and I was asking my a2 how to
pronounce it
po po de que Sal wait boudic a show we
are running a little bit late would you
let them know also we're about to eat a
lot of cheese so I'm gonna prepare my
stomach
I don't know this actually works by the
way it's not fine definitely proven hey
Google Tech's mijita were on the way so
that's a message to my ADA saying
on the way wanna send it or change it
send it send it oh thanks Google all the
Domino's are in place I'm gonna finish
eating this Clementine or tangerine
which one is this
I don't know the difference hi my name
is Juliana Calvo I'm a chef at pampas of
Rio and we want to show you how to make
phone de queijo so Maya this is a
restaurant that you like a lot I can
tell us about this place but besides
that system of getting your food and
then waiting your plate instead of just
pained by menu items and that is the
most traditional way of eating in Brazil
the first time I went it was feeling
like home what does Pampas mean and what
is the name common purpose is a region
in the south of Brazil traditionally the
farmers raise calls for this that's
where the shoe haskell is more popular
to Haskell is barbecue in Portuguese and
it's the way we roast the meat why did
you pick this appetizer for our potluck
I feel under occasion was the thing that
he lead in Brazil he will find
everywhere that you go in the country so
we went to Brazil and we had fallen to
get you every single morning to make the
owned occasion we need the yuca starch
butter olive oil eggs a little bit of
salt and a good blend of cheese here we
use dried Mina's and partners of cheese
and what is Yuka Yuka is a root cheese
bread was first made because was very
hard find wheat flour so they have to
produce their own flour with what they
had which were
the UK after 30 minutes the publication
will grow and you can see the little
ball popping and when it's golden brown
it's perfect to be heated we will be
eating this at the potluck in a few days
[Music]
the smells like a cheese cracker oh yeah
buddy make the Bobo that's why it's like
a little damn yes and that very nice
really starchy and like you like how
would you say wow this is tasty
that's a boy to bomb I do bong yeah you
think will pair well with a wrestler oh
definitely we're gonna serve this first
is that everybody's hungry and then yes
there so how do you say cheers in
Portuguese how would you solve or at the
Andrew would say how do you say it
resilient
[Music]
that was a towel and now we're on our
way to our friend Janos house you know
is a tasty producer actually she's gonna
be making one of her favorite family
recipes each smell sense
wow this [ __ ] has really just turned
out to be a ploy for us to get lots of
people to impress hey we're cooking -
that's true but you know if I we I mean
you are and I'm gonna watch you welcome
to my kitchen
so for your holiday potluck I'm going to
be making some kind of beef samosas
you had these before never know so
samosa is a filled pastry from India
through the Middle East into like East
Africa so if you don't like shrimp
across all of that land everyone has
like a samosa some people call it
sambusa so the meat filling is pretty
simple I use the ground beef because
that's probably the most common way
you'll have it in Kenya however the
spices I use are kind of just the ones
I've grown to like I'm using whole
cardamom pods cumin and coriander
so I toast and grinding up the spices
just so they get maximum flavor without
having to put too much of it some red
onion and it has to be very very finely
chopped green onion garlic as well as
those spices and then for some heat I
don't know the type of chili we have in
Kenya because a word hasn't translated
but the Serrano I found to be like the
most similar so if he's aren't the most
traditional ingredient but my mom has
always put them in there and I like it
because it adds in a little bit
sweetness which contrasts like the
spices and then that seaweed so let's
talk about the
making them ago the part that my mom
does cuz it's like so it's a really
simple dough in there I put some flour
salt a little bit of olive oil water and
just mix it together with my hand once
it starts forming into one dough dump it
out on the surface and certain kneading
it and then it says to hang out for like
a half hour and that allows for
everything to marry together and why did
you select for this because it's a
holiday party samosas are likely go-to
for any Kenyan person like if you turn
up to Christmas Thanksgiving Kenya
person's house samosas are there that's
why you don't want to show up on like
super super African people time because
there'll be no cymose as well I think
you're gonna like them but I'm gonna
need a little bit of help okay I am Han
state I'm the touristy bad in the
kitchen but oh well don't worry it is
like very traditional for everyone to
get their hands in it's social that's
when you get all the gossip when
everyone like fills in the updates as
you're rolling things yeah I see we're
getting there making a pretty good
square anything does it feel them can
you if you hold it up can you see light
through it there's a lot of flower
blocking your window I divide it and
then part cook it on the stove just to
get rid of that stickiness
this part is deceivingly frightening
this is my face I don't know what it's
called if air has a name I brought it
back from Kenya a few years ago but I
use it any time there's like a flat
front it's so easy because it's flat and
it's heavy it's good home security oh
yeah
so I'll cut it you to quarters and then
I'll have from that triangle I fold it
into a cone using a glue just flour and
water that would be the piece to seal up
all the edges oh that's too much I'm
ready to start filling fill it not too
full just below that front lip you're
gonna tuck in this portion to really
lock it in there and then glue it shut
I'm gonna fold that flap over paying
attention into corners like last time so
curly until those corners are fully
sealed that's it thank you any good
smells mine cracked at the bottom you
just want to gently lower them into the
oil nothing let's hang out so the final
step you just want to give it like a
little pat with paper towel and then I
think it's only appropriate and
responsible to try oh yeah yeah but it's
very importantly serving like it like
already has fur but like it blows it up
the damn in my mouth has been open the
saliva is coming through so how are we
gonna do lime then bite or bite lines I
think I'm gonna lime that bite I'm also
gonna line then bite and lime
oh wow that isn't good this literally is
like it's called a days I'm I'm reading
Oh mom this is by far the best of us
I've ever had mm-hmm thank you
we have to give props to mom she's the
one who taught me thank you so much for
contributing to the potluck
my pleasure wait to have these on a big
day if you're gonna be a crowd favorite
oh yes this is gonna be so good
and then episode one but stick around
because next episode we're highlighting
some very special dessert
gonna see an old friend don't go
anywhere that your computer but next
week
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]